growing up on a dairy farm you learn why
they had five kids Labor's a lot cheaper
that way and so we spent the summers
working out in the and the grape
vineyards you really learned the value
of hard work growing up on a farm learn
the value of community graduated from
the same public school that my dad and
my grandfather my brothers graduated
from I was a page in the US House of
Representatives my junior year of high
school so here you have a little farm
boy from Southwest Michigan that never
spent much time off the farm going off
to Washington DC working on the floor of
the house going to school of the Library
of Congress really learned a lot in
terms of how to be involved in in
politics and really make make a
difference after high school I applied
to a lot of different in schools but
Hills I just felt the most at home with
that they want to teach how to learn
instead of what to learn I thought that
was very important so after I graduated
managed to campaign for a person running
for the state Senate provided me a lot
of knowledge and understanding of
fundraising and dealing with the media
and approving mail pieces and TV and all
the stuff from the political side that's
needed to make the policy work in
February of 2010 I decided to come back
home and decide it was time for me to
step up I thought I could make a
difference that what was happening up in
Lansing wasn't working I quit my job
didn't have a paycheck for ten months
and I just went out there knocking doors
throughout the entire district in the
fall I was able to win by 30 points and
so there was a stamp and we came in that
fall with the Republican majority in the
House Republican majority in the Senate
a Republican governor and we rolled up
our sleeves and we got to work for the
citizens of Michigan I served by six
years three two-year terms that's the
maximum you could serve in the house
governor Snyder called me up and asked
me if I wanted to work for the
administration offered me the role of
lottery commissioner and drew the single
person in charge of the entire state
lottery Bureau 3.1 billion dollar sales
organization
oh I'm very blessed and proud to to have
received this and I hope I can live up
to the standards that hell's Dorsett
[Music]